John Legend everybody
[Applause]
alright not only a great challenge but a
great citizen you use your powers for
good and not evil I try I try it that
and it's a terrific new video and song
what if if people don't hear it some of
our audience is you know older than
listen to you yeah that's the poetic how
would you put it in what is where was
the take away well the song we talked
about you know we've had another gun
massacre today in America and Illinois
and every time it happens we get the
hopes and prayers and thoughts and
prayers from all our officials and they
don't do anything about it you know and
the song is basically saying we've had
enough of the thoughts and prayers and
they're talking about it let's actually
do some T&P yeah before I forget this I
haven't seen you you were so good as
Jesus oh thank you and Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ Superstar you were born to
play that part people already think of
you as a great guy well you know it's
like Jesus John Legend I get that I'm
not I'm a kid of I'm gonna son and
grandson of preachers and so I've been
learning about Jesus my whole life yeah
so I guess that was preparation for that
okay yes so alright I know mass
incarceration is a big issue with you
yeah organization involved with yes Free
America do you do you think Trump gets
any credit for he did get a bill passed
yeah a prison reform the bill was good
and it was Lee says no one ever writes
about it when I do something good when
no one notices the press that we're
mentioning it now okay [ __ ]
mentioning
how about that it's hard to really
credit up because you know he has no
idea what's in the bill but but a lot of
people worked on it on both sides of the
aisle and a lot of activists worked on
it and it it's aptly named first step
because there's a lot more steps I think
that need to go into place but I think
it is a first step and it's better than
not having done it yeah you know when
Hillary Clinton ran her first speech in
their campaign was about mass
incarceration so I thought when they
hung that super-predator on her it was
kind of unfair she she said it she said
it so she has to be accountable for what
she said but I think well I think the
pressure that was put on her and her
realizing that she had to move to the
left on that issue was because of the
pressure and so I think it's good for
activists on the left to pressure
Democrats who in the 90s and the 2000s
were well she's up on crime she was okay
but there was a lot more crime in the
90s according to according to the
Clintons on this I mean she was the
first lady at the time she wasn't the
president and she said they were saying
that word in response to requests from
community leaders the bottom line is I
think the pressure that the left put on
Hillary Clinton was useful and it moved
her to the left and it moved the
Democratic Party to she needed to be
moved to the left on that issue on
criminal justice absolutely and I think
a lot of Democrats have needed to move
to the left and we're saying sure but
we're saying people bring up other
candidates for 2020 there their record
on criminal justice and I think it's
appropriate for people on the left to
put pressure on our part of the and and
require them to step to where we want to
understand but part of the result of
that was that I remember reading the
quote from Colin Kapernick who said I'm
not gonna vote because they're both
racists that's a terrible idea because I
hate that but that's what happened
that's not think we can have both we can
say let's put pressure from the left on
our politicians but also say
when it comes down to a decision I vote
for Hillary Clinton and
I campaign for Hillary Clinton because I
knew the alternative was Trump and not
not just a negative decision because I
thought Hillary was a great candidate
too but also it was clear that even if
there was someone running on in
third-party candidacy to her left I
wouldn't vote for that person because
I'm practical about the fact that I want
the best candidate with the best chance
of winning to get my vote okay so I
noticed that you're pretty much the only
big star in the arc le recent
documentaries or we all watched and it
was pretty damning yeah
and I think a lot of people have asked
in the last few years like when is the
me to movement going to come to the
music industry and I think what a lot of
people of thinking is god that's so
ubiquitous in the music industry where
would you even start yeah I don't know I
mean I think clearly we're having this
conversation about our Kelly there's
another article this week in the New
York Times about another musician and so
I think there's a conversation being had
I just think music is probably a bit
more decentralized and so I think and
sexy in the art Kelly case the reason
why I was ignored for so long was
because the victims were pretty
powerless and they didn't have right
speaking up for them and so that's
really why I spoke up I have friends who
were activists that we're speaking up
for those victims and a lot of people
were ignoring them and the guy who wrote
about it in Chicago was saying I learned
as a white guy writing he was like I
learned that black women are the least
bad women in society because when I was
writing about this no one cared no one
paid attention so these victims didn't
have the power they didn't have the the
standing to get their get attention paid
to to what happened to them and so it
was good that this documentary and made
proper attention to
can we still play r.kelly at a party
would that be wrong if i i don't play me
neither
it's absolutely not out of my out of my
iPod
you